Hello. I'm Craig, and this is Crash Course
Government & Politics, and today I'm gonna
take a deep dive into political science theory
and try to figure out why interest groups form.
So grab your snorkel, no, this is a
deep dive, grab your scuba gear.
I know, I know, you're probably thinking that
interest groups form to influence the government
with their piles and piles of cash, so the
way they form is by amassing piles of cash,
and then, well, who really cares once they
have all that cash? Maybe that's true, but
why we have some interests that get together
in organized to influence policy and others
that don't is an interest-ing question.
[Theme Music]
So as you remember pluralist theory proposes
that every group with a particular interest
should be able to form an organization that
will pursue policies to further that interest.
So if I like birds, which clearly I don't,
I should be able to join up with other bird
fanciers to work with the government, so that
it protects birds' wildlife habitats. I hate
this analogy. And in fact there are a number
of interest groups out there that can do this,
including the Sierra Club and the World Wildlife
Foundation.
I respect those clubs. I don't hate all eagles,
just that eagle. But this doesn't mean that
everyone with an interest can form a group.
Like, I like video games, I'm not going to
go form a group about it. Why doesn't every
interest form a group? Well political scientists
would cite collective action problems.
These are the problems that occur because
people should work together, but don't.
The classic example is building a road that
many people could use but no one individual
could build on their own because, you know,
building a road is hard.
Although there are obviously some situations
where people can coordinate to get things
done without any government intervention,
most of the time if you want to accomplish
big things like the Hoover Dam or building
the highway systems, you need some sort of
government action to make sure it gets done.
And usually it gets done when the government
collects taxes from everybody to build the
road. Now some people may use the road a lot;
more than their taxes paid for, and some may not
use it at all, but the government collects taxes to pay for
it all the same because otherwise it wouldn't get built.
One special type of collective action problem
is called free riding. This is when people
who stand to get a big benefit from a project
either don't pay a big enough share, or they
don't pay at all because they know that the
project is so important that it will get done
whether they contribute or not. Then they
will get the full benefit of the project - say
a pothole free road - without paying a dime.
Get it? Free ride? (Singing) Come on a take
a free ride".
This becomes a problem when other people,
not wanting anyone to get a free ride, also
refuse to contribute to the project and, you
guessed it, it doesn't get done.
'The free rider problem is worse in larger
groups and this partly explains why some interests
are better represented in American politics.'
Because large groups are more anonymous, it's
easier to free ride; there are lots of other
people who probably care more than a single
individual and, knowing this, the single individual
rationally chooses to free ride.
Also, the larger the group, the easier it
is for an individual to claim that their efforts
don't matter which is a smaller version of
the voter paradox. Finally, with a large number
of members, it's much harder for a group to
enforce it's rules against slackers, who don't
pull their weight young man! Or woman - young
person!
What this means in practice is that smaller
groups are more successful in forming and
pushing their agenda, this is why producers
are more successful at forming interest groups
than consumers, and why business owners are
usually more successful then workers.
Now, many people will say that in the US labor
is well represented through unions, but over
the last forty years at least union membership
and the dues that come with it are shrinking
and unions are less able to get legislation
passed.
So how do large groups solve the collective
action problem and actually coordinate to
get things done? According to political scientist
Mancur Olson they do this by providing selective
benefits to their members. In other words
they build membership by providing perks.
These can be material things like special
services or discounts on things like insurance,
or smaller things like baseball caps or bumper
stickers.
One of the largest organized interest groups
in the US, the American Association of Retired
Persons, or AARP provides a number of material
benefits to their members including discounts
on a number of useful products and services.
AARP also provides many of the second type
of benefits, informational benefits. Interest
groups can inform their members of policies
that may affect them, and can provide guidance
about what to do in order to influence these
policies.
The third type of benefits are called solidary,
and they refer to friendship and comradery
that can come from being a member of a group.
Ah, that's my favorite benefit.
Solidary benefits also include networking
opportunities, and networking probably has
a lot to do with why people join professional
groups. Gotta do the schmoozin'.
The final type of benefit that can help build
interest groups is called the purposive benefit.
This is a feeling that by being a member of
a group, you're helping to make a difference.
Purposive benefits partially explain why so
many people joined up with groups during the
civil rights movements, it certainly wasn't
for the SNCC keychains.
Another way that interest groups can be formed
is by political entrepreneurs. These are specific
individuals who make extraordinary efforts
to bring people together for the purpose of
changing policy. Often political entrepreneurs
are politicians who recognize the latent potential
of groups that haven't yet organized. When
successful, they benefit electorally.
One of the most famous examples in American politics
was Claude Pepper who realized there were a lot of
older Americans in Florida and that if he became their
champion and organized them, they would vote for him.
Even more well known than Pepper, was salt
(Chuckles). No, Robert Wagner, whose sponsorship
of the National Labor Relations Act was so
important that it's often still called the
Wagner Act. This helped create political power for labor
unions, and unions helped keep Wagner in Washington.
I guess we also have to talk about the elephant,
or if you're a Democrat, the donkey in the
room; lobbying. Lobbying is an attempt to
influence policy by persuading a government
policy making official. As we say when we
talked about iron triangles, this can be done
by providing officials with information that
they can use. But most people still think
of it as providing campaign contributions
in return for favorable policy outcome.
There's no real evidence of this quid pro
quo bargaining, probably because it's really
close to bribery and therefore doesn't happen
that much. But it has happened in the past
and this idea is pretty powerful, especially
if you think all politicians are corrupt.
But there is more to lobbying than this, especially
in the eyes of political scientists, who like
to divide lobbying into insider and outsider
strategies. Insider strategies include directly
trying to persuade elected officials, and
also using the courts. Actual direct lobbying
of congressmen has become more difficult over
the years.
Congress has passed laws that have limited
the ability to deduct lobbying expenses from
taxes, and restricted how much lobbyists can
pay for official's travel expenses. This has
cut down a lot on the famous political junkets which
often looked like a vacation paid for by lobbyists.
Congress has also passed laws limiting the
gifts that lobbyists can give to officials
which now have a value of no more than fifty dollars.
So no free Apple Watch for you congressman, sorry.
You could probably get Grand Theft
Auto V at this point though.
While it's mostly elite groups that are able
to lobby congressmen, executive department
heads or even the President directly, other
groups have been more successful using the
courts as an insider strategy. One way to
do this is through direct lawsuits like the
one that led to the Brown vs Board of Education
decision. Another way is by finding plaintiffs
and funding their lawsuits, the old "find and
fund," they call it. No one calls it that.
A third thing that interest groups can do
is file amicus curiae, or "friend of the court"
briefs to get their legal ideas into Supreme
Court decisions.
Groups on both sides of the political spectrum
pursue all these avenues, but environmental
and civil rights groups are known for going
after the courts. In particular the courts
are often the focus of minority groups, since they're the
ones least likely to be successful in electoral politics.
The other types of lobbying strategies are
called outsider strategies, let's explain
that in an animated way by going to
the Thought Bubble.
Outsider strategies are those that involve
interest groups mobilizing the public. Sometimes
these strategies are called grassroots lobbying.
Mobilizing public opinion is sometimes called
"going public", but this is very confusing
because it's the same term used to describe
the President's making direct appeals to public
opinion. And also it happens when a company
floats it's stock on an exchange for the first
time.
When interest groups go public the main things
they do are organize advertising campaigns,
organize protests and engage in grassroots
efforts to get their membership to lobby officials.
Advertising campaigns are expensive, so you
don't see a lot of advertising on behalf of
things like poverty relief. The best know
recent example of an interest group sponsored
advertising campaign was the Harry and Louise
campaign, sponsored by healthcare groups and
doctors that was designed to stymie President
Clinton's attempts at healthcare reform.
Interest groups organize protests to get the
attention of politicians and the media, and
protests can be effective as we saw during
the civil rights movement. Protests can also
help to form interest groups, like the Occupy
movement during the height of the financial
crisis after 2008. Some protests, such as
labor strikes, can impose costs on business
owners, and push them to lobby office holders
more directly.
Grassroots lobbying occurs when an organized
group encourages its membership to contact
elected officials, often through letter writing,
emails or telephone calls. This is becoming
increasingly prominent because of the new
rules that limit traditional lobbying, and
because technology makes it so easy for groups
to reach large numbers of people, and to get
them to respond directly to elected officials.
But beware, sometimes technology makes it
easy for well financed groups to give the
appearance of being a large-scale grassroots
organization, when they really aren't. These
bogus attempts at grassroots organizing have
been called astroturf lobbying, and one of
the few examples where political scientists have
demonstrated  their superiority at naming things.
Thanks Thought Bubble. So interest groups are all
about changing policies, and they pursue both insider
and outsider strategies to influence policy makers.
I hope that we've given you a balanced view
of interest groups, one that's not so cynical
about the way they function in our politics.
Thanks for watching, I'll see you next time.
Crash Course Government and Politics is made
in association with PBS Digital Studios. Support
for Crash Course US Government comes from
Voqal. Voqal supports non-profits that use
technology and media to advance social equity.
Learn more about their mission and initiatives
at voqal.org.
Crash Course is made with the help of all
of these collective actions. Thanks for watching!